So I'm going to read you something. I get some I had a lot of mail
And I don't know where I got this I've been a lot of different places in the last week
And this showed up at one of them, and I'm going to read it to you. I have no idea what to make of it
It's written in a female hand
So that's about all I can tell but there's no address or name on it
This isn't a question
but a comment, or more accurately perhaps a message I
Spent this past weekend in an ayahuasca ceremony
Which for those of you who don't know is a South American?
Visionary plant medicine some of you may roll your eyes at this
But ayahuasca brings you into direct contact with the archetypal realm of being
users of this medicine
Initiates I should say refer to ayahuasca as she
Because the spirit of the plant is decidedly feminine an encounter with ayahuasca is an encounter with the great mother of creation
The Goddess the void from which all things come the feminine counterpart of logos
Dr.. Peterson
You appeared in one of my ayahuasca visions
might account for why I've being ripped rather fatigued lately
Dr.. Peterson you appeared in one of my ayahuasca visions, and I asked
Asked her who is Jordan Peterson. What is he doing? Which is something? I'd really like to know as well and
She responded with Crystalline clarity
quote
Here he is here to invoke and initiate the divine masculine principle on Earth at this time
So I'm up here to thank you
Deeply and profoundly on behalf of the great mother
herself to Goddess the Divine feminine principle who has been eagerly awaiting the awakening of the masculine principle into
divinity and service
So you know get a letter like that every day?
Actually, I get a letter to like that every day
so you know what went through my head when I read this and this is of course and completely crazy parallel but
We know one of the things I learned to do as a psychotherapist was just to tell people who were talking to me
What came into my head?
It isn't what I'm thinking exactly because that's not exactly the same thing you know
What comes into your head is more like a dream it comes unbidden?
It's like your imagination if you're thinking there seems to be like a voluntary element of that, right?
I mean some who God only knows how we think but it seems partly voluntary at least and
Jung thought about carl jung thought about it like a dialogue between the conscious mind and the unconscious mind. There is a constant
Continual dialogue, but when things just pop into your mind
It's not much different than walking into a room having something there which is an observation
I also derived from jung by the way because he pointed out quite rightly that people don't really think that
Thoughts appear to them now you can think because you can take the thoughts that appear to you
and then you can subject them to criticism and
Elaboration and so on instead of just assuming that they're true right off the bat, but people often don't do that
They just something just pops into their head and then they assume that it's true
anyways one of the things that I tend to do in psychotherapy is just to tell people what pops into my head because
Well, why?
Because then the person that is talking to me gets one person's
Untrammeled opinion not even that reaction not opinion. It's not really an opinion. I don't think an opinion
Maybe is what I think later, and there's this personal flavor to it
What popped into my head?
Was the story about socrates you know?
He had this when he was being put on trial by the Athenians for corrupting the nation's youth
Something I've been accused of by the way
Although it's not self-evident to me that it's me doing the corrupting
He said that somebody had asked him once had asked the delphic oracle once and the Delphic oracle was this
retreat that you could go to if you were an ancient Greek citizen and you'd
Be there, and you'd have a dream and then you'd go ask the delphic oracle to interpret it and nobody really knows
What was up with the delphic oracle?
Today how that worked exactly, but she would interpret your dream in any case
and
somebody once asked her who the wisest man in Greece was and
The Delphic Oracle said it was socrates because he knew he didn't know anything
That's essentially the story not popped into my mind. It's a crazy comparison, but
You know I have a crazy mind, so I guess that's how it works out
so
Now one of the things I'm going to do today
Which I haven't done before
Because I'm going to read you a little bit of I told you I finished my book last week
And I haven't read it read it to anyone. I have given it to a couple of friends to review
one person in particular
screenwriter named Greg Hurwitz has been unbelievably
Helpful. He's so fast and so sharp at this sort of thing and I can send him like a
Twenty Page Dense Twenty page
Manuscript and he'll rip it to shreds and send it back to me in like 90 minutes
It's just unbelievable he's so good at that. He's been very helpful, but I haven't
No one else has seen it apart from my editor
and I haven't read it to anyone so but some of it seemed particularly appropriate for
tonight's lecture
So I thought I would start the lecture tonight by reading a little bitter that and it's it's from a chapter
It's on the issue of sacrifice as such this is Abraham and Isaac
This is a very strange little testament story right. This is one of the stories
That's contained in the old testament that makes modern people think that maybe we should just not have that punch to do with the old
testament per say it at all and
especially with regards and maybe you shouldn't have anything to do with the god of the old testament either because I mean as far as
Abraham is concerned
God tells him to sacrifice his own son now it turns out that God was just kidding
So to speak you know I'm obviously being Flippant but you know it does raise the question
What do you make of a divine being who would who would?
require such thing such a thing or
Conversely, what do you make of Abraham? Who would have such delusions either way? It's a little hard on the
What would you call modern believability and Moral integrity of the old testament, but these are very very strange stories?
and they're not what they seem to be or they are but and they're more so
We're going to talk a lot about sacrifice tonight, and here's some of the things that I've been thinking about sacrifice
So this is from this book. It's called
Twelve Rules for life an antidote for Chaos and it's coming out in January
Which I think I mentioned and this is from Rule 7 which is do. What is meaningful? Not what is expedient?
and so here's
here's some of
The writing I've been doing over the last three years on meat on the motif of sacrifice
I'll start with just a brief intro before I read this
It took me a long time to understand
What was meant in the old testament by Sacrifice and which is strange because once I figured it out
It seemed bloody obvious. It seemed like oh, yo, obviously that's what it means, but
Lots of times if you figure something out correctly it seems self-evident as soon as you've figured it out correctly well
We'll see how that goes, but you know it seemed to work for me anyways, I
Knew that of course at least implicitly I knew of the modern usage of the idea of sacrifice everyone
understands that motif is that if you want to make things better in the future, then you suck make sacrifices in the present and
Maybe you even do that
Multi-generationally in fact you most definitely do if you're a good parent, I mean you and that's just I would say that's a really
particularly typical of of Immigrants right because immigrants
often come from
Terrible places and have to undergo terrible things to come to a new community where they get a rough?
reception and have a hard time getting their life going and
A big part of the reason that they do it is to make their lives of their children
better and luckily when they come to Canada
Usually given where they came from that actually works because where they came from is worse and here is better even though
No, you know immigrants often have to struggle to to get on their feet again
Have to learn a new language and become acculturated and face the fact that they're not part of the mainstream culture and well
You know many of you know the whole story, so the idea that you make sacrifices
For the future and you make sacrifices for your children
And that's everyone understands without and it's part of being responsible and mature and shouldering the burden of being
Properly and you do that for yourself, too
if you're disciplined in fact that's almost what discipline means it discipline means that you're capable of making sacrifices because
You're not disciplined if you just do something you want more rather than something that you're doing that's not discipline
That's maybe that works and great if your life is working out that way great man, but that isn't that isn't discipline
this is plan is when you want to do something right now and
Instead you think no, I'm going to force all my gratification
Maybe forever but certainly for a very long period of time medium to long period of time and you
concentrate on something that you think will bear fruit in the medium to long run and so you look into the future and
You decide that?
By making today a little less impulsively pleasurable shall
We say you'll make tomorrow a little bit more secure and productive and then you actually do it, too
And that's difficult you know and we discussed last week
Adam and Eve's discovery of the future and
and the revelation of the possibility of the future including the possibility of
Tragedy and suffering in the future and and it's our knowledge of the possibility of tragedy and suffering in the future that
motivates us to
Sacrifice in the present so that we can reduce the unnecessary
Anxiety and uncertainty and pain that awaits us now. That's a negative way of putting it
We're also doing it so that you know we can have some joy
and we can make life better in all of that and and that's not trivial, but the
fundamental issue
Especially once you have small children this fundamental issue is to save the suffering the hell off, right?
That's what you want to do
That's your primary Moral obligation if you're a person who has any if your eyes are open at all. That's your primary
obligation and so you make the sacrifices that are necessary and you set up the future and
Well the the motif of sacrifice
Is there in the old testament?
But it's more it's so concrete that it's difficult to draw a parallel between the two at least for me. They didn't align
Self-eVidently, and I don't remember in my rather limited
religious education as a child in the united church because I went to the united church till I was about 13 I
don't ever remember anybody pointing out that like the sacrifices that cain and Abel were making or the sacrifice that
Abraham was supposed to make or sacrifices that people were making to God were the car were the
precursors, let's say the dramatic
precursors to the psychological idea of Accra feist that we all hold as civilized
People in the Modern world, so although it seems obvious as I said once you lay it out it
I don't remember that ever being explained to me
But and then well and then let me read this so now that I've sort of introduced it. Here's what happened as
humanity developed
first were the endless tens or hundreds of thousands of years prior to the emergence of
Written history and drama the Twin practices of Delay and Exchange
Began to Emerge slowly and painfully so here's a cool psychological study
So it's called the Marshmallow test
And maybe it's even a reliable study even though it was done by Social psychologists. It's probably replicable
Um and it's a nice study, so you take small children and you
bring them into a room and you put something that they would like in front of them a marshmallow and
You then you torture them basically you say
See that marshmallow and the kid thinks yeah, I see that marshmallow. It's like
you can have that marshmallow right now, or
If you wait, I think the experiment is ten minutes
then you can have two marshmallows and
so that puts the child in quite a conundrum because
They're being asked to trade an actual concrete tangible Marshmallow for two hypothetical future
marshmallows and
it's not that easy to conjure up a hypothetical future reality that has the same tangible significance as
Something real right in front of you, and so it's amazing thing that people can do that and so
Then the experimenter leaves and some children grab the marshmallow and just you know chomp that thing down right now
Other kids they videotape kids
while they're waiting
And they do all sorts of things they whistle they look at the ceiling they sit on their hands you know they try to distract
themselves course they're eyeing that marshmallow like a squirrel lying and not and and trying to
Restrain themselves, and you know what I see in that is that
The child's Prefrontal Cortex the higher cortical systems are warring with the underlying
Motivational systems more primordial motivational systems that govern such things as hunger the hunger system
hypothalamic system says there is something sweet and
Fat right sitting there right bloody now grab that thing and stuff it down now
And I'm sure many of you have a constant battle with your hypothalamus with regards to sweet and fat things and often lose
so you can feel
Some sympathy for the child but and the hypothalamus has these tremendously powerful
Tendrils upward into the Brain
Into the parts that we would associate more with voluntary control and the voluntary control centers have these little weak
Ribbons going down to control the hypothalamus since it's pretty obvious if you know something about neuroanatomy
What part is actually in charge when the chips are down and it's not easy for children to learn to regulate those underlying?
Primordial impulses the ones that are wired in the ones that we share with animals
But they do it and and and the cool thing is
This is what Walter mischel found. He's the guy who did the study was that?
the Long-term
Outcome for the children who can delay gratification in the Marshmallow test is much more positive than it is for the children that
Are impulsive and eat the marshmallow?
Instantly its delay of gratification now
It's likely that that's associated with trait conscientiousness although that
Specifically has that specific connection has not yet been established, but they seem conceptually very very similar
So so anyways
this emerges and children
Probably between the ages of 2 and 4 something like that
They should have it in place by four because it's very difficult for them to
really interact well with other children without having that delay of gratification in place because you can't delay gratification other kids don't like you because
You're you want everything your way, and you want it now and your lot
You're liable to temper tantrums, and that sort of thing you haven't got the kind of self-control necessary to make you fun to play with
So you can see that emerging in children, and it's pretty it's pretty interesting and and not only that if it it predicts positive
Long-term Outcomes just like trade conscientiousness does by the way because trade conscientiousness is the second best predictor of long-term success
over the Lifespan in Western Cultures
Its second after intelligence and so in our societies
The people who do best across time are the people who have high Iqs and who work hard and I would say that's a pretty
decent
What would you call it?
It's a validation in some sense that our cultures are working properly because what you would want
I would say if the system is working meritocratic. Ly like it should and if you're trying to extract resources
From those who can contribute at a higher rate?
Than what you would want to have happen is that the hard-working smart people do better?
Hopefully if that's the case then everyone does better hopefully
anyways
So you can see this developing in children first where they endless tens or hundreds of thousands of years prior to the emergence of written?
History and drama the Twin practices of Delay and exchange began to Emerge slowly and painfully then they became
represented in metaphorical abstraction as
rituals and tales of sacrifice
It's as if there's a powerful figure in the sky who's judging you you better keep him happy or look the hell out
We've been watching ourselves deal with him for a long time. He seems to like it when you give up something you value
so
Practice sharing and sacrificing until you get good at it
No, one actually said any of this so long ago although they said
Something very similar, but it was implicit in the practice and then in the stories
action comes first
implicit comes first people watched
The successful succeed and the unsuccessful fail for thousands and thousands of years
And we thought it over and we drew a conclusion the successful among us
Sacrifice the successful among us delay gratification
a successful among us bargain with the future and then a great idea begins to Emerge in ever more articulated form
That idea is the point of a long and profound story
It's the moral of this story, and I'm going to engage in some foreshadowing here
What's the difference between the successful and the unsuccessful the successful sacrifice?
And things get better as the successful practice their sacrifices
the question becomes increasingly precise and
simultaneously
broader
What is the greatest possible sacrifice for the greatest possible good?
You know if you if you push a question in a direction perhaps there comes a time when you can't formulate it any more
precisely and broadly and
and
That that's the point at which the question in some sense and perhaps even the answer the question becomes our Katha Pollitt it becomes archetypal
Because it it can't be
bested and
This is like an ultimate question in some sense
How are you going to ask a more broad-based question than that, what is given the initial?
Presuppositions that you have to make sacrifices
Then the logical end point to that is something like okay if you have to make a sacrifice
What's the greatest possible sacrifice and for the greatest possible good that's a good question the answer becomes
increasingly profound
for the God of Western Tradition like
So many gods requires sacrifice. We've already examined why but sometimes he goes even further and
Requires the sacrifice of what is loved best?
This is why and this is another one of Mankind's
fundamental discoveries
Sometimes things do not go well that that's self-evident, but here's the rub
Sometimes when things are not going well, it's precisely that which is most valued that is the cause
Why it's because the world is revealed through the template of your values if the world you are seeing is not the world you want
therefore
It's time to examine your values
It's time to Rid yourself of your current presuppositions
There's a famous experiment that I've alluded to a couple of times. I believe in this lecture series
The invisible Gorilla experiment and in the invisible gorilla experiment. There's two teams of
players each with three members one dressed in block and the other dressed in white and each team is
passing a basketball back and forth to the team members and milling about
you see a video of them doing so they basically fill the video screen and
The white team is passing a basketball to the white team members and the black
team is passing a basketball to the black team members and
Your job as as far as the experimenter is concerned is for you to count the number of times that the black
block team yes black team
Passes the basketball back and forth so that's what you do
so now you have an ambition and a name and a value and
The ambition and the Aim and the value they're all the same thing and that is to perform well at the task now the thing
That's so cool about this, and this is really so cool. It's just
unbelievably
It's just unbelievable that this is the case. It's like a complete validation of a certain element of the buddhist worldview
So they passed the ball for a couple of minutes and then the experimenter says to you
how many and you say 15 and because you're happy and you're happy with yourself because you've been paying attention and and
The experimenter says yeah, that's right or maybe not
Maybe you missed one and then the experimenter says did you see the gorilla and half of you say what what?
What your real eye like really and he's in the experimenter says yes
And then he rewinds it and plays the video and like a minute and a half into the 3-minute video sure enough
In walks this guy in a gorilla suit six foot three or so
Stands in the middle of the game right in the middle of the game the same size as the players
perfectly obviously
evident the his chest for like a second and a half and then sort of saunters off and
Half the people who?
Watch the video don't see the gorilla
And which is absolutely shocking and what that means is that your ambitions blind you to the nature of reality?
Now they illuminate some reality
But they blind you to most of it, and that's fine because you're not
Does not allow to you in some ways you're a very pinpoint thing like a laser beam
And so you just can't be attending to everything all the time
But one of the things that you might ask yourself once you know that is that if you're suffering dreadfully then one possibility is that?
You're so fixed on the point you're so fixed on a point
The fact that you're so fixed on the point that you're fixed on might be integrally related
To why things are going so catastrophic Aliy wrong
now perhaps not because you know there's a lot of arbitrariness about life and
Perhaps you suffer even when you don't deserve to that seems to happen in the book of job for example because job is a good
Guy and God has a bet with Satan which seems like another relatively nasty thing to do to let's say it just torture
And he does quite nicely
to see if he'll
Turn against God and it seems like a rather
playground sort of thing for God to engage in but the point is is that even in a
Document like the Old testament, there's Ample
Suggestion that sometimes people just get wiped out and hurt even if they're living good Moral lives
Aiming properly and all that there's an arbitrariness in life you that's not
It erratic low, but it's possible that
It's what you're clinging to
That's hurting you and it's even possible
That's the thing that you're clinging to the hardest that's hurting you the most that could easily be someone you love like lots of times
I see people in therapy, and they're miserable for one reason or another
Sometimes it's because they have a very close relationship with a family member and that
Just isn't working you know the family member for the sake of simplicity
Will say is not really oriented towards helping them have a good life the family member is instead oriented towards
making them as bloody miserable as you can possibly make anyone and and
What would you say exploiting the the bond between family members in order to enable that and then?
sometimes
The sacrifice that's necessary is either
Merely distancing yourself from that person
sometimes substantively and sometimes
seriously distancing yourself from like
we don't talk anymore ever and so that's pretty damn rough and it hurts and all of that, but
but
it's a good example of the fact that sometimes in order to
Extract yourself from the miserable bit of Chaos that you happen to be enmeshed in you have to let go of what you love best
If the world you are seeing is not the world you want therefore. It's time to examine your values
That's really worth
It's really worth thinking about you know because the alternative to is to curse fate
Right because if it isn't you and there's nothing you can do to change there
Isn't something you're doing that's wrong then it's faith itself. It's the world itself
It's other people let's say because they're a huge part of the world or it's the nature of the world itself or or its God
himself in whatever
Form you either believe in or don't believe in because it's fundamentally all the same in the sort of situation that I'm describing
So and one of the things that's really interesting and I mentioned this before about the israelites in the old testament is that they?
They got this right. It's really something because what happens to the israelites over and over in the old testament is that
they get all puffed up about how wonderful they are and then they make moral errors because they're arrogant and
Then God comes along and just cuts them into pieces for like generation after generation
And then they wobble back to their feet and but they always maintain the same attitude. Which is we did something wrong
We did something wrong. It's like. It's like it's like an axiom
Rather than observation is that if we're not if things are not laying
Themselves out for us as they should be then we cannot curse. God we have to look to ourselves
Well, you think well why not curse God?
Because maybe it's his fault
That's a really good question and one of the things that I've tried to figure out over the last 30 years is well
Why not just curse God because there is this arbitrary element to existence and we are?
Vulnerable, and there is a plenty of suffering and things are unfair like there's problems, right?
There's injustice and unfairness and all of these things and endless suffering
So why not just lay at the feet of God and the whether God exists or not in some sense by the way?
With regards to the metaphysics of this particular discussion is not relevant
it's the point remains the same either way and the answer is as far as I can tell that if you
Refuse to take on the responsibility yourself
And you attempt it to lay it at the feet of either society or being itself then you
Instantly start to act in a way that makes everything much worse not only for you
But for everyone else and maybe even for being itself and so no, it's not helpful
Now if you're if you decide that it's you, you've got the problem
Maybe that's not even true like maybe you are someone who's being tortured by the bet between God and Satan
And like too bad for you, if that happens to be the case, but it still seems to be the appropriate thing
For a human being who's standing on his or her own?
Two feet in a proper manner to take the responsibility on for themselves
Regardless of the counter-Arguments that might be made against it. That's really something
It's time to Rid yourself of your current presuppositions. I also think of that. It's a deadwood issue
You know one of the things you see with motifs like the pair of the Phoenix
Remember when harry potter goes off to fight. He's like st.. George. He goes off to fight the
The hell is that thing the basilisk that turns you to stone when you look at it's a dragon for all intents and purposes
Its guarding a virgin bird. What's her name for it's not Virginia. It's close to that though
Ginny Ginny Ginevra, right which is a variant of virgin and very introvert for Jigna well when he gets bitten?
by the Dragon and
Poisoned that's the dragon of Chaos right the thing that turns you to stone when you look at it when he gets
bitten by it then he's going to die and
Yeah, well if you get bitten by the thing that turns you to stone when you look at it
If it bites you man, if you're not dead, you're going to wish you are
it's one of the two and
Then the Phoenix flies in and cries tears into the wound and that heals them and the Phoenix is the thing that
Allows the dead wood to burn off
Occasionally let's say well, it's I think it's once every hundred years with the Phoenix and of course
It's pretty dramatic the whole damn bird has to go up in flames, and then there's nothing left, but an egg
But there's a very serious message there, too
Which is that you know you can compare yourself in some sense to a forest fire to a forest
You know in a forest has to burn now and then for the deadwood to clear so that the forest can actually maintain its continued
Existence and if you stopped the forest from burning for a prolonged period of time which happened in the United States
when they were trying to manage the forest fires too tightly
Then all that happens is the dead wood accumulates and accumulates and accumulates and accumulates and accumulates
Until the whole damn Forest is dead wood and then lightning hits it and it burns
So hot that it burns the topsoil off, and then there's nothing left nothing grows, and so that's a good moral
Lesson which is don't wait too long to let the damn dead wood burn off. You know maybe a little self-immolation
on A
daily basis might be preferable to burning yourself all the way down to the Bedrock you know once every 20 years or so because maybe
There won't be anything left of you when you do that
and you know that happens to people all the time I've seen that happen to people many many times the
Dead wood accumulates the mess around them Gathers the Chaos that they haven't dealt with accumulates, and then one day the spark comes
And they burn so far and so fast that there's not enough left of them to recover
And then they're the people who've been eaten by the beast
They're they're people who've been eaten by the dragon and now are inside its belly another very common archetypal motif and well
Maybe a hero will come along and rescue them or maybe they'll just stay in there forever
And that's a precursor to the idea of hell, and it's not something I would recommend
So a little medicine on a regular basis
Is a lot better too than total emulation?
On terms other than your own
sporadically
It's time to Rid yourself of your current presuppositions. There's another segment
See in the soviet union with solzhenitsyn wrote about the soviet union
comments Pathologies it
It's sort of peaked in terms of its pathological authoritarianism when it became illegal to complain that your life wasn't going well
and you just think about how horrible that is say because
Because you know lots of times your life, isn't going well. I mean, and I don't mean this in some casual way
I mean
Maybe I don't know maybe have diabeetus in your you know maybe you're gonna lose your your feet or something like it's really not
it's nothing trivial that's going on here something is not good or maybe it's economic or maybe you're unemployed or and
But you see the idea in the soviet Union was well. We already have all the answers
everything's perfect already
that's what totalitarian is fake well, if everything is perfect and
you're
suffering then
well, maybe there's something wrong with you because
Everything is perfect after all and if you're suffering then what are you to come out? And say well? I'm suffering
It's like well, then your evidence that things aren't perfect right you're like a widow or an orphan in an old testament story
You know when the kings got to high and mighty then they?
Wouldn't pay enough attention to the widows and the orphans and then the profit would come along and say you
know those widows and orphans a
Lot more important than you think they are and if you don't pay attention to them properly then
things are going to fall apart around you in a way that you just can't even imagine and
So well then you're sort of like your own widow and your own orphan
But you don't get say hey look you know things aren't perfect yet, because I'm actually having still quite a rough time here
You don't get to admit to your own suffering
If you can't admit to your own suffering then you certainly
See the suffering
Especially the additional suffering the excess suffering should be treated as evidence that you're not doing something quite right yet?
It should be treated as evidence that you're wrong
There's something important that you're doing that's wrong. I understand
How harsh that is and I'm not saying that everyone who's suffering is suffering because they're doing something in some simple way, that's wrong
I was in a elevator once in a hospital
It's a very terrifying thing and this person got on who was just in an absolute state of shock you know
I mean it was really
not good and
I don't remember how this happened, but I engaged the person in conversation
and they just said that they had just had been diagnosed with what looked to be terminal cancer and
What was horrifying about it was that what they were doing was?
Going over their life in the elevator
trying to figure out what they had done in order to deserve such a fate you know they've immediately taken it on themselves as a
Moral failing and that's not what I'm saying you can't
Come up to someone who has cancer and say well if you weren't such a bloody idiot throughout your whole life you wouldn't have cancer
And believe me that happens a lot more than you think and people who have diseases like that get blamed for it
That's not what I'm saying. It's not like that. It's it's it's it's a more generalized attitude
That is that if life isn't yet what it should be then you have a response you have a primary responsibility to do something about
It and the place to start looking is
to your own errors and to fix them and that's and that's that's
That's a safe bet man, because you're probably doing some things that you
Would wouldn't have to be doing that if you fixed would make things better
So it's time to let go and to sacrifice who you are
For who you could become?
There's an old story about how to catch a monkey
In case any of you aren't interested in how to catch a monkey now you now you're going to know how to do it
First you have to take a large narrow necked Jar
Just large enough in diameter at the top
For a monkey to put its hand inside then you have to fill it partway with rocks
So it's too heavy for the monkey to carry then you scatter some treats near the jar to attract them and you put some inside
inside the narrow neck jar a monkey will come along if you're lucky and
Grab the
You know goodies, but he'll want the ones inside the jar, too
So then put his hand in there and grab what's in there?
And if you've set up your monkey trap properly then he won't be able to eat his hand out
Because he's got good goodies
Not without unclenching his hand not without relinquishing what he already has
The monkey Coucher can just walk over and just pick up the monkey because the monkey isn't
Into the whole sacrifice thing because he's just a monkey you know and so you can catch him as a consequence of his own
Unregulated hypothalamic desires, you know and to be. What would you say?
Charitable to the monkey if you put out candy or something like that's like how often does a monkey get candy
He's probably a little more motivated than you are to not let go but you can get the point
The Monkey Catcher can just walk over to the jar and pick up the monkey the animal will not sacrifice
The part for the whole that's actually a pretty good phrase. It's the animal that will not sacrifice the part for the whole
Perhaps this story is apocryPhal, but as an eccentric pSychology professor once told me
Fiction lies to you in the most truth in the most truthful possible Manner
something valuable given up ensures future prosperity something valuable sacrificed
pleases the Lord
Those are equivalent statements ones
more articulated
I would say that's the first statement then the second one is more dramatic and more embedded in a collective religion dream. You might say
What's most valuable and best sacrifice well obviously that depends on the culture and the time?
What is at least emblematic of that a choice cut of meat?
Well if you're a herdsmen for example that that's a big deal with I mean generally speaking throughout human history meat has been a very
Valuable Commodity as it is by the way among chimpanzees
Chimpanzees hunt they like to hunt colobus monkeys, and you know they'll they'll basically start eating the damn monkey alive they weigh about 40 pounds
Despite the fact that the thing is screaming away
And that's pretty interesting because one of the things that indicates is that male monkeys that male chimps
They're the ones that do the hunting aren't really
inhibited that much when they're in hunter mode by what you might describe as empathy and
there's certain elements of human behavior that are reminiscent of that you see that sort of thing emerged now and then in
Human Battlefields when groups of men
seem to
Abandon all
internal regulation whatsoever to a degree that makes you wonder if internal regulation even exists
So it's kind of meat. Well meats valuable you know and this is a good document by Richard, Wrangham
I think while back a book about the human invention of fire
And I think I told you a little bit about this wrangham claimed that we invented fire discovered fire mastered it
Maybe two or three million years ago
That's a long time longer than people had thought and that that's what actually transformed us physiologically from our chimp-like
Ancestors into the Sort of Svelte creatures
we are now because it's a lot easier to digest cooked meat and meat is a tremendous source of of
nutrition energy
Raw materials all of that especially if it's cooked so me, it's a big deal cook meat is a big deal
and maybe it's a choice cut of meat the
Kind you might offer to a guest if you're not a I always say this wrong said vegan
Vegan or vagin. I always think vagin, but that's wrong. That's that's a star vague as a star, right?
They're not like star creatures. They're they're yeah
Anyway, so you know you might offer that especially
Especially if a guest came to your abode and you were I heard
Man, you might sacrifice a high-end animal and offer your guests a nice choice cut of meat and that would actually matter
It would mean something
From the best animal in a flock. What's above even that well in terms of the thing you could sacrifice
Well your best animal that's good. Well. How about you? How about your child? How about you? Well that would be next on the
Hierarchy it's kind of hard to get past that right, and I think it's a it's a toss-up whether
the Sacrifice is
Greater if it's you or if it's your child. I would say being a parent that it's greater if it's your child
because I think most people who have established a
I
Hate I hesitate to say proper, but I'm going to anyway. It's a proper relationship with their children. It's if push came to shove
They'd take the bullet and let their kid go live
The sacrifice of the mother is exemplified profoundly by Michelangelo's great Sculpture the Pa de
Mary is contemplating her son crucified Andrews, so that's his body after he's been crucified. It's her fault it was through her
He entered the great dream of being so what's the meaning of this sculpture? It's a great sculpture. It's just an absolutely unbelievable
Sculpture you just can't believe that someone could exist who could make something like and of course it wasn't the only thing
Michelangelo made right it was like. That's it. It was something he just tossed off in a couple of months while he was doing other
unbelievable things, but you know
It's it's an it's an object of contemplation. Which is why it's in a great cathedral in a great city
It's an object of contemplation and the idea is something like
Well what what's the role of a mother if she's awake I?
Had a client come see me a while back not very long ago
Woman in a boat who's about 30 and trying to make decisions about her life
She was pretty career oriented and so I asked her about
Although maybe having a bit of trouble with career. I've seen this many many times, so this is an amalgam. This is a story
That's an amalgam
and I talked to her about
The other elements of her life. It's like well, you know
There's only five things you do in life. So you've got your career down. You know. What do you do outside of your career?
That's meaningful and engaging
How are things going with your family could be your family of origin your siblings?
Whatever if you have an intimate relationship and like what's your plan for your own family?
And apart from those five things there's sort of something like get some exercise now
And then don't eat too badly and try to stay away from the drugs
You know that's that that kind of and the crime that kind of lays out
Life, and if you miss any of those five things or if you do any of those other things wrong
Then you're in trouble, and you can get away with missing a couple of them
But not all of them you know and she said something along the lines of well
I'm not sure I should bring a child into this world
I thought oh God christ you got to come up with something better than that such a bloody cliche
Which is what I told her I said you know you must have thought that up when you were 16
It's like really that's here that you can't do any better. This is a very very smart woman
It's like really and this can't do any better than that like yes, obviously this is a vale of tears
And you know a well of suffering and all of that. You know if you ask 30 people who are
Wondering about having children. Why they're wondering 20 of them will say that and so that that tells you how original it is
It's not original at all. It's not a thought
It's like this little it's like a it's like a it's a mean something that lives in your mind
It's not a thought, and it's certainly not something
It's certainly not something that you should just take it face value in and say oh well
I'm not having a family then it's like no. No you kind of look at that, and you criticize it a little bit
It's like well the pop
It's the other one. That's the other one. That's very common. There's too many people on the planet already I
Really don't like that statement
It's like just who are you going to ask to leave just how are you going to get them to leave?
You know it's a serious question and who says there's too many people what the hell is wrong with people anyways
so or
ruining the planet yeah
It's like I think it was the club of rome
Who who prophesied by the way that there would be so many people on the planet by the year?
2000 that there would be widespread starvation, and they were completely and utterly wrong about that
And I think it was the club of rome who either compared us to a virus or a cancer on the face of the planet?
It's like oh really that's what you think about people hmm. Aren't you something isn't that something to think about human beings?
Viruses and cancer, what do you do with viruses and cancer invite them in and make them at home?
It's like no you try to eradicate them
You've got a bloody well watch your metaphors folks because it isn't clear that you come up with them or that they run you
So you better watch them?
so anyways Mary
You know and Mary's the great mother right that she's the mother that's what Mary is
Whether she existed or not is not the point she exists at least as a hyper reality she exists as the mother well
What's the sacrifice of the mother well that's easy if you're a mother and you if you're a mother who's worth her salt
You offer your son to be destroyed by the world. That's what you do. That's what's going to happen, right?
He's going to be born he's going to suffer. He's going to have his trouble in life. He's going to have his illnesses
He's going to face his failures and catastrophes and he's going to die
That's what's going to happen and if you're awake, you know that and then you say well perhaps
He will live in a way that will justify that and then you try to have that happen
And that's what makes you worthy of a statue like that
but still the sacrifice of the mother
Is it right to bring a baby into this terrible world?
Well every woman asks yourself that question some say no, and they have the reasons
Mary answers yes, Voluntarily Mary is the archetype of the woman who answers yes to life
Voluntarily that's what that image means and not because she's blind
She knows what's going to happen and so she's the archetypal
Representation of the woman who says yes to life knowing full
Well, what what life is not Naive?
not someone who got pregnant in the backseat of the 1957 Chevy you know in one in a one night of
Half-drunk idiocy, not that but consciously
consciously knowing what's to come and then also allows it to happen because that's another thing that's a
Testament to the courage of mothers my mother was good at this my mother's a very agreeable person too agreeable for her own good
But that's what happens if you're agreeable because you're too agreeable if your own good, that's the definition of agreeable
And so she's a nice person, and it still is luckily she's still alive and we've had a very good relationship, and I have always
been able to make her laugh, which is which is a good thing and but she was tough cookie that woman, you know if if
remember once she came across I
was out playing in this baseball diamond little diamond and
Empty lot really in this little town. I grew up in and I
Was about ten and she walked by I was there with bunch of my friends
and I was about to have a fistfight with this little tough kid that I hung around with and
There were half girls on the team and this fight had
Some relationship to status maneuvering
you know in
Relationship to that anyways, we're going to have a fight and my mom walked by she took a look and I could see from her
Demeanor that she knew exactly what was about to happen and she looked
For a second and then she walked by and I thought whoa good work mom, no kidding
It's like last bloody thing I needed at that moment was
For her to come charging up and say you boys aren't planning to have a fight. Are you it's like well yeah, mom
We're we were actually planning to have a fight and now that you came and intervened. I actually lost before the goddamn saying even started
So two thumbs up for Mom
She was also the person that said because I had some trouble with my dad when I was you know it adolescence
He had some trouble with me. So you know
It was 50/50 that's for now. It's probably
70/30 with me on the seventy end of the being the trouble and anyways I left home when I was about Seventeen and
She said something really interesting when I left home. She said it was too. Good at home. You never leave. I thought hey mom
That's pretty good. You know for for an agreeable person. You've got a real spine man. So that was pretty good
so
So you know mother that's as this the mother into the person who also says
Get out there. Take your goddamn lumps because you're tough enough so that you can handle it. She doesn't say
You just stay down there and your bedroom brooding away
because the world is unfair and treating you badly and
Your suffering is too much. She says yeah, there's a lot of suffering out there, but
You're a hell of a lot tougher than you think you are
so
In turn Mary's son Christ offers himself to God
So completely that his faith and trust in the world is not broken by Betrayal torture or death
That's the model for the honorable man, so
You know you have an interesting dynamic there you have the woman who's willing to make the sacrifice
lays the groundwork for the son who is willing to make the sacrifice that
Works out pretty nicely and it's a good thing to know in
Christ's Case however as he sacrifices himself
God his father is
Simultaneously sacrificing his son right that's one of the oddities of the trinitarian model is that God?
Sacrifices himself to himself same thing happens in Norse Mythology, right?
Norse Zeus Germanic Mythology
Zeus sacrifices himself to himself he actually hangs on a tree. It's actually wounded in his side. It's very interesting parallel
But I think part of the idea is well
The human Human Race is starting to work out. What's the ultimate sacrifice?
it's something like that ultimate sacrifice of value well the the
Passion story, and I told you I was foreshadowing. I'm bringing cysts into
Consideration things we won't talk about for a long time. Maybe not at all in this lecture series
I don't know because I don't know how far. I'll get is that well
There's a supreme sacrifice demanded on the part of the mother and there's a supreme sacrifice
Demanded on the part of the son, and there's a supreme sacrifice
Demanded on the part of the father all at the same time and then that makes the supreme sacrifice
Possible and hypothetically, that's the one that renews. That's the sacrifice that renews and redeems
It's a hell of an idea man and the thing about it. Is that I?
Don't know if it's true, but I know that its opposite is False
And generally the opposite of something that's false is true
It's it's opposite as False
It's because if the mother doesn't make the sacrifice then you get the horrible eatable
Situation or something like that in the household which is just its own absolute catastrophic hell
And if you want a really good insight into that I would say watch the documentary crumb
See Ru and be a man that's been rated by some critics as the best
Documentary ever made and it is some piece of work man
It is the only thing I've ever seen that actually lays out the eatable catastrophe, and it's full nightmare
You know so you could you could look at that?
so if the maternal sacrifice isn't there then that doesn't work if the
paternal Sacrifice isn't there, you know if you're if the father isn't willing to
Put his son out into the world let's say to be broken and betrayed and all of those things then
That's a non-starter because the kid doesn't grow up, and then if the son isn't willing to do that well
Then who the hell is going to shoulder the responsibility?
So if those three things don't happen then it's cataclysmic
It's chaotic as hell. If they do happen is it the opposite of that well, you could say well
Maybe it depends on the degree to which they happen and and it's a continuum
How thoroughly can they happen well we don't know you know because you might say
How good a job do you do?
Of encouraging your children to live in truth
Let's say well, that's part of the answer to this question and the answer likely is well, not you
Don't do as good a job of it as you could so it works out quite
well
but you don't know how well it could work if you did it really well or
Spectacularly well or ultimately well or something like that
You don't know and you know people have an intonation of this because one of the things that's really cool about having a young, baby
This is something you don't know until you have it. There's two things you don't know
Mmm. There's a lot more than two
There's three things you don't know
Until you have a baby the one is that you didn't grow up yet
Because you actually don't grow up until someone else is more important than you you can't
So people think they grow up if they don't have children
but they don't they just think they do now there are some people who make sacrifices of other Sorts, but
This is a whole different ball of wax as far as I'm concerned. It's not a very Elegant metaphor, but
You learn that it's kind of relief relief not to be the center of attention. That's cool
that you can sit back because of course your child in your family and
in societies immediately the center of attention
and so unless you're narcissistic then you allow that to happen and
Then you learn all sorts of really good things about other people because other people really like babies. It's so cool
I lived in Montreal when we had our first child and I lived in a pretty rough neighborhood by Montreal standards, right?
It's like you know material has such a great city like Toronto. It's like even the rough neighborhoods
Are they're more like charming with a little you know dark underbelly something like that
But there were some rough characters in our neighborhood
It was pretty poor and we'd we'd push her around in her stroller
And he's like grizzled rat dole guys would come by
They'd look at her and they just light up and they'd come over and like smile at her
And you know you just saw there the positive element of their humanity just well forth you
Ask there s to be something seriously wrong with you if you don't respond that way to a baby you know
I mean, this is that that's not good
That's not good
But it was so cool to see these people you kind of give them
Generally sort of walk four feet around them on the street. You know and yet. They were all of a sudden all that
The layers that were on them would just fall off and they'd be so and the babies are sort of like public property weirdly enough
To sort of like pregnant women you know because people often treat pregnant women sort of like. They're public property too
I mean in a positive way. Oh, whoa. Lord you would have a baby yeah, and you know they hey well
They do all Sorts of cute things
so
So you know the reason I'm telling you that is because there's a strong
Impulse in people to note that there's something
Miraculous about the existence of a new human being and the Miraculous element is all the potential that's there right?
That's all there. Is there is potential and
With every birth. There's the potential for something
remarkable to be
Introduced in the world, and you know one of the things I've thought too is the other thing you don't know is that?
babies are Generic until you have one and then
Your baby, isn't a generic baby at all. It's like
Instantly it's a person with whom you have a relationship that's closer perhaps than any relationship that you've ever had and that
You can keep perfect
right because most of the relationships you've had already are with people who are screwed up in 50 different ways and so are you but
Here you've got this baby and like it be care, but it's not rained yet and so
You know you have this possibility of maintaining this relationship?
that starts out that baby really likes you and
Generally that continues for quite a long time as there are two years old you come home
They're really happy to see it's kind of like having a puppy. You know. It's like. They're thrilled when you come home
It's like how many people are thrilled when you come home, you know so he'll see you again. It's like
No, not a little kid a little kid is thrilled when you come home?
and you can keep that going and so there's this pristine element to the potential relationship between
Parents and children that's Terribly devalued in our society terribly
It's almost as if we're willfully blind to it, and I think it's an absolute catastrophe because there's nothing is very little in life that
Can compare to establishing a proper relationship with with child?
They make great company a few
if you keep your relationship with them Christine
And so you know it's worthwhile, you think well
I'm so so the reason I'm telling you. This is because people look at infants, and they think
They think this could be the potential savior of mankind
That is what they think that's how they act
So that's what they think and the thing is it's also true
Now how true it is I don't know
But that's I think probably because I think it's probably because people don't dare to find out that's how it looks to me
in
Christ's Case however as he sacrifices himself
God his father is simultaneously sacrificing his son it is for this reason that the Christian
Sacrificial drama of son and self is archetypal nothing greater can be imagined. That's why it's an architect
You can't push past it
so
That's the very definition of archetypal. That's the core of what constitutes religious
the greatest of all possible sacrifices is self and child of
that there can be no doubt pain and suffering define the world of that equally there can be no doubt the
Person who wants to alleviate suffering who wants to bring about the best of all possible futures who wants to create heaven on Earth?
Will therefore sacrifice everything he has to God?
to life in the truth
So that's a page and a half from the book. I'm going to release in January
so back to genesis that were all we already up to genesis four and
Adam knew Eve his wife and she
conceived and
Bare cain and said I have gotten a man from the Lord now
This is after Adam and eve have been chased out of the garden of Eden right, so what's really cool about this
I really think that the out of the cain and Abel story is the most profound story. I've ever read
Especially given that it's you can tell it in 15 seconds
I won't because I tend not to tell stories in 15 seconds as you may have noticed but but you can read the whole thing
that quickly and
It's so densely packed that. I just can't it's it's actually
Unbelievable to me that it can be that densely packed okay, so the first thing is is that
Adam and eve are not the first two human beings can enable are the first two human beings
Given Adam and Eve were made by God and they were born in paradises like what kind of human beings are those you don't know
Any human beings like that human beings aren't?
Born in Paradise and made by God human beings are born of other human beings
Right and so so that's the first thing and it's post-fall. We're out in the world world in history now. We're not in some
Archetypal Beyond although, we are still to some degree not to the degree
That was the case with the story of Adam and eve. We've already been thrown out of the garden. We're already self-conscious
We're already awake. We're already covered. We're already working
We're full-fledged human beings and so you have the first two human beings
can enable
Prototypical human beings, so what's cool?
Is that humanity enters history at the end of the story of Adam and Eve and then the archetypal patterns for human Behavior are?
Instantaneously presented it's it's it's absolutely
Mind-boggling and it's not a great. It's not a very nice story, right, so they're they're brothers. They're are hostile brothers
They've got their their their hands around each other's throat, so to speak or at least that's the case in One direction
So it's a it's a story the first two human beings
engage in a fratricidal
Struggle that ends in the death of the best one of them
that's the story of human beings in history and
That man that doesn't give you nightmares. You didn't understand the damn story
Now in in these hostile brother stories which are very very common
often the older brother cain is
Used and this is very true in the Bible, but it's true in all sorts of folktales and all sorts of stories
of all sorts for that matter
See the older brother has some advantages. He's the older brother in a
agricultural Community the Older Brother
generally inherited the land
Not the younger brothers and the reason for that was is that well let's say you have like eight sons
And you have enough land to support a bit of a family and you divide it among your eight sons
Then they have eight sons and they divided among the eight sons
it's like
Soon everyone has a little postage stamp that they can stand on and starve to death on and so that just doesn't work so you
You you you hand the land down in a piece to the eldest son, and that's just how it is
It's tough luck for the rest of them
But at least they know they're going to have to go and make their own way
It's not fair, but there's no way of making it fair
well, so the oldest son has some
you might say he has an additional stake in the
stability and
And the stability of the current hierarchy he has more of a stake in the status quo
So that makes a more of an emblematic represent
Representative of the status quo, and perhaps more likely to be blind in its favor. It's something like that
So that motif creeps up very frequently in the Hostile brothers archetypal struggled so cain
fits this the story of cain and Abel fits this pattern because cain is the one who won't budge who won't move
He's stubborn, Whereas the younger son. Who's abel is often the one who's more?
Not so much of a revolutionary, but perhaps more of a balance between the revolutionary and the traditionalist something like that
Whereas the older son tends to be more
traditionalist
Authoritarian at least in these
metaphorical representations an
Adam knew eve his wife and she conceived and bare cain and said I have gotten a man from the Lord, so
There's the first human being cain. It's like I told you that the mesopotamians thought that mankind
Was made out of the blood of the worst Demon that the great goddess of Chaos could imagine?
Well the first human being is a murderer and not only a murderer a murder of his own brother
And so you know old testament that's a hell of a harsh book and you might think well
maybe that's a little bit too much to bear and then you might think yeah and
Maybe it's true too. So that's something to think about I mean I
human beings you know like
They're amazing creatures, and to think about us as a plague on the planet is its own kind of bloody catastrophe
Malevolent Low
Quasi Genocide all metaphor
But that doesn't mean that we're not without our
Problems and the fact that this book that sets sits at the Cornerstone of our culture would
present the first man because a murderer of his brother is something that should really set you back on your heels and
Again, she bear his brother abel and abel was a keeper of sheep, but cain was a tiller of the ground
There you see a very old
representation there's
Abel there
And he's got his sheep up on the altar and cain is bringing a sheaf of wheat and I don't know exactly what's happening here
With the blood but or it's a ray perhaps
It's something like that, but the overall impression of the image is that something transcendent is
communicating with this sacrifice
And you can see that so you think oh how primitive you know how primitive these people were sacrificing to their God
It's like you know
Those people weren't stupid and this is not primitive
Whatever it is. It's not permitted. It's sophisticated Beyond belief because
The idea as I already pointed out is that you could sacrifice something of value and that that would have
Transcendent utility and that is by no means an unsophisticated
idea in fact it might be the great idea that human beings ever came up with
It's an answer to the problem. That's put forward in
The story of Adam and Eve right because we became self conscious
and then we discovered the future and then we knew we were going to die and then we knew we were vulnerable and then we
Became ashamed and then we developed the knowledge of good and evil, and then we got thrown out of
Paradise is like. That's a big problem. So what the hell are you going to do about it? Well?
Sacrifice that's the hypothesis. Well that's a hell of a hypothesis man. That's what we're doing
you've made plenty of sacrifices even to sit in this
Theater and many people made plenty of sacrifices to have a theater like this existed many people made sacrifices
So that we could actually freely engage in the dialogue that we're engaging in in a theater like this
And so it's like all of this is built on sacrifice and sacrifice bloody well better work because we do not have a better idea
Sacrifice what's the counter position?
murder and Theft
So let's go with sacrifice shall we and perhaps. We won't consider it. So damn primitive. You know because it's not so primitive and
Again, she Barrett his brother abel and abel was a keeper of sheep and cain was a tiller of the ground
now some people have read into this the
Eternal Battle between Herdsmen and
Agriculturalists, it's raged in the American west for example because the Herdsmen like to have their herds sheep cattle go
wherever they were going to go and of course they had your cultures the farmers like to have things fenced off and
So and the agriculturalists actually won in the final analysis
But anyways abel is a keeper of sheep, and that's interesting because that makes them a shepherd
and I think that's part of the critical issue here because a shepherd I
Talked a little bit about shepherds before you know if you look at Michelangelo's statue of David which is another?
Stay during work. I mean that David. He's no
Trivial figure and of course
David who Slays Goliath right and Goliath is like
the giant of the patriarchal enemy, it's something like that and
You know middle Eastern shepherds they had to keep take care of sheep
And they're edible and the lambs are very vulnerable and there were lots of wild animals around. It wasn't like
England in the 16th Century
it was like there were lions you know and
You had a slingshot or a stick or some damn thing and so your job was to keep the sheep
organized and not let them eat by the lions alone and so
you had to have a clue and be tough and self-reliant and all of those things had to be tough and
self-reliant you had to be able to take care of a lot of vulnerable things at build do it on your own and
So that's all built into the shepherd
Metaphor and it's you know
It's a tough thing for it's not a great metaphor for modern people because we tend to think of the shepherd is someone like little
Lord Fauntleroy, you know like some little
Certainly not a lion killing
Hyper-Masculine Lion killing you know monster
That's not a shepherd the shepherd sort of dances around and you know it's not that's not the metaphor here. That's that's
That's not the metaphor here so abel was a keeper of sheep
but cain was a tiller of the ground and
In the process of time it came to pass that cain brought of the fruit of the ground an offering unto the Lord
okay, so he's participating in the sacrificial ritual and abel he brought of the firstlings of his flock and of the fat thereof and the
Lord had respect unto Abel and to his offering
Now you don't know why that is and this is a built-in ambiguity I think
Now I think there's textual hints, but I'm not sure
Abel brought the firstlings of his flock and of the fat thereof okay, so so, what does that mean well?
He brought high courts a high quality sacrifice. You don't know that Abel's sacrifice is low quality
Because it doesn't say you know abel brought. God some wilted lettuce and then burnt it he didn't say that
but but there isn't a sentence there that talks about how
high-Quality cain sacrifices
But in any case the Lord had respect unto Abel and his offering
So there's a hint that abel's putting a little bit more into the whole sacrificial thing than then cain
But there's also a hint that maybe God is just like liking you a little better than he's like in him, and that's I think
Useful from a literary perspective because there is that arbitrariness about life you know with my own children for example
One of them has had I would say
heat
things come easy to him
He's lucky fortunate
However, you want to put it. He seems to be that sort of person. Where's my other child. It's like. It's just like one
horrible job like Catastrophe after another and it's so strange to see that because as far as I can tell there's
the character logical differences are
Certainly not accounting for the for the for the difference in destiny
You know my want the one child who's had so much trouble. I mean as a child
was just a wonderful child so
Mazing ly happy and easy to long with and fun
and
Had a terrible time of it. So who knows what god's up to
But distributing fate equally certainly isn't one of them
And the Lord had respect unto abel and his offering but unto cain and his offering he had not respect
And cain was very roth angry
Roth is a tough word. You know when these are translated many times
It's hard to get the full flavor of the words, but roth and his countenance fell well to have your countenance fell
This is sort of up to fall is to
To have it be heavy depressed
For sure angry for sure resentful
Probably roth that's anger so cain is not a happy clam
That his hard work is being rejected by God now. That's worth thinking about
Really because you think about how human that story is you know you're out
There well we could say
You might be a useless character
And you know you're whining about how catastrophic
Your life is and it's a pretty much obvious to everyone around you and you that it's your fault
You just don't try you don't wake up in the morning. You don't get a job
You don't engage in things you're cynical and you're bitter
And you're angry and you don't try to help the people near you
and you don't try to fix up your own life and you don't take care of yourself, and you know and
Then things go wrong. It's like well really what do you expect but then but that's done
I mean that doesn't mean someone in that situation will just say well, that's okay. I deserve it and they'll be happy about it
They won't they'll be absolutely bitter about it and angry, but you know
Put that aside for a moment there are people who seem to struggle very
Forthrightly let's say and still have one catastrophe after another happened to them and so
It's there's no easy answer in this in this
It's like you can
fall fall afoul of God
Because your sacrifice is our second rate or you can just fall a fall of God
And you don't know why well tough luck for you, and then what happens in either case is exactly this almost inevitably
Cain was rocked in this countenance fell well you know you meet and I
people like this write to me all the time I've seen so many many of them as clients you know they say they're
20 not so often 30 more commonly sometimes 40 their lives haven't gone
Well, you know they're in a pit of despair of one form or another and not only are they in a pit of despair
But they're extraordinarily angry about it, and God only knows what they would do with that anger if they had the opportunity
To give it full voice
Right you know one of the things I've always thought about hitler. Is that you know people
You have to admire Hitler. That's the thing
Because he was an organizational genius
You know the thing that doesn't stop people from being hitler the thing
people don't
Refuse the ambition to become hitler
Because they don't have the genocide emotive ation
They don't follow that pathway because they don't have the organizational genius
They've got the damn
Motivation and you know if you take a hundred people randomly, and you talk to them and you really talk to them you'll find that
Five percent of them would take their vengeful thoughts
Pretty damn far if they were just given the opportunity and in fact they do because they make life
Miserable for themselves and often for their family and sometimes for anybody they can come near and then maybe another
Twenty percent of people have that bubble up in them on a pretty damn regular basis, so you
Know you can have some sympathy for cain if you don't have any sympathy for cain, then you're not
So you can't enable also they don't just represent to our contempo types of being they represent
So it's not like you're cain, and you're able in here cain. You're able. It's like you're half-and-half, and you're half-and-half, and you're half-and-half
It's something like this. This is two different potential patterns of destiny, and you don't manifest one purely and the other zero
It's like you're it's it's like the line between good and Evil that runs down the human heart
It's exactly the same idea and maybe you're more like cain, or maybe you're more like Abel
But they're still a little cain in you. No matter how able you are and maybe more than a little and
Probably more than a litter little and if you watch your fantasies, which I would very much recommend
you'll find that they
Show you dark things about you. That will shock you if you
Allow yourself to be conscious of what you're thinking, so
It's a good time when you're having an argument with someone especially someone that you love
To just watch the pictures that flash in the back of your mind
That's part of let's say coming into contact with what carl jung called the shadow and the shadow is the manifestation of cain
That's a perfect way of thinking about it and one of the things that jung said about the shadow
Because jung was not someone you mess around with lightly
He said the human shadow has roots that reach all the way to hell and jung meant that that's no metaphor for him now
He might not have meant it in the same way that a fundamentalist Christian from from the Southern us
Might mean it but I would say that young men sit in a way, that's far more terrifying and also far more true
so and
cain was very wroth and his countenance fell
So there's abel
Burning is offering away there
and he's in this sort of
relationship with
Let's call him
the
archetypal figure of
Culture the archetypal father and
it's something he respects that's the thing it's an indication that the posture is an indication of respect and
then there's cain in the background you see in his face is in Shadow and he's
He's jealous of what's happening here, and he's going through the motions perhaps, and maybe God just doesn't like him
We don't know, but he's going through the motions and he's not very happy about it
And you know that that's actually a phrase that you could you could carve into many people's
Tombstones as an epitaph for their life which would be went through the motions, but wasn't very happy about it
This is really an interesting one. I think I mean so I don't know what God is doing here exactly but
He's helping ignite the sacrificial flame
And that's kind of an interesting idea. I think because
You know let's say that you have an impulse to make a sacrifice you think
Well, I should change this about my life. Well. It's like where does that come from that impulse
It's just well, just it manifests itself out of nothing so or you came up with it
Well, you might want to stop thinking about that
Thinking so surely that you come up with your own thoughts. You don't come up with your damn dreams. Do you?
They just happen
Kanade only knows where they come from they come from your brain. Oh boy. That's a sophisticated answer they come from your unconscious
Well, that's not much better at least it's somewhat better
But there are those matan amazing dramas take place in the theater of your imagination at night?
You don't even understand what they are and yet they occur night after night and those things dreams. They can contain wisdom. It's just
Well it just staggers the person who has the dream once they get the key to the dream once they remember it's like
Oh look you just revealed a bunch of wisdom to yourself that you didn't know well. Where'd that come from?
Well, you don't know how in the world can you dream up things that you don't know?
That's a tough one. Maybe we'll talk about that at some point in this lecture series because there are some
Reasonable things that can be said about that, but you know the idea that
There's something that's not you young would call it the self karl
You would call it the self which he thought of as the totality of your being across time and space
it's something like that and that you know each second that you exist is a
slice
Manifesting itself across time and space, and he thought of the the self is partly the voice of conscience
Whatever that is that helps guide you when you have to make a difficult decision and a difficult decision might be well
What do I need to sacrifice? What is how do I need to discipline myself right? What do I need to forego well?
How do you figure those things out well?
You know this picture is trying to put forth the idea that perhaps if you had established the proper relationship with God the father
We've talked about what that might mean then he would help figure out how to get the sacrificial fires burning
So that you could stay in a proper relationship with him across time well, that's such an unreasonable
Proposition it what's the alternative?
proposition
Well this isn't working out very well. That's for sure. You know kate seems to be doing it. I don't know what it is
It's like it's as if he thinks he can only do it himself or maybe he wants only to take credit for it or something
Like that he's not in this
Grateful let's say and inquiring grateful and inquiring
Posture because that's what a perfect posture should be it should be grateful and inquiring and grateful is thank God things aren't worse for me
Than they are
And you should be grateful about that because they could be a lot worse than they are man. They can be so bad and
Inquiring would be well. I don't really know how I could make it better, but I'm open to suggestions man
If I can figure out how to do it, I'll try it
That's the in that's the humility and the inquiry that's a humble inquiry. How could I make things better?
It's something like that, and that's like what sacrifices. Do I need to make in order to make things better
That's a good question to ask yourself
You could ask yourself that every morning
What sacrifice do I have to make to make things better you can decide what constitutes better?
How about that then it's not even as if it's being imposed on you come up with your own notion of what?
Constitutes better you know we try to make it sophisticated should just be better for you cuz that isn't going to work very well
Right you you're just going to fall downstairs if you do that because you have to live with other people and decide
Stupid anyways. What are you gonna? Do like?
Can't even nothing you can even say about that. It's so
That that's the doubts the attitude of a very badly behaved hyper aggressive
two-year-Old and I mean that technically and so you could
You could ask yourself well how I have this day that lays itself out in front of me
What thing could I let go of that's impeding my progress?
That if I let go of would make my life better
My Family's life better my cultures life better my being better
And then that would give you something to do for the day wouldn't it and to justify your miserable life
Because you need that that's the whole point of the first story of Adam, and eve. What do you have a miserable life?
Okay
What am I going to do about that?
Well if you just have a miserable life you're just going to suffer stupidly and get bitter about it. That's what happens to cain
It's like well. How about not doing that because that seems to just take a bad deal and make it worse. How about?
Making a sacrifice and seeing if you can please God and put being on track
God that'd be something to do what could be better than that. What could possibly be better than that
Well, that's why it's archetypal man, because nothing's better than that. That's where it tops out
So when you can do that you can do that every day you have to do it a little way because like
what good are you you know you're not going to go and
Bring this socialist utopia into being in one fell swoop
You might also think that you know one of the things came might figure out here
There's a couple of things that just aren't going right for him
downwind of the fire not the right place to blow from and
The fact that he's in hand velop tin haze and smoke and breathing it in and the fire isn't burning
Might be an indication that he's doing something wrong or he could be wiping his eyes and saying Jesus
What kind of stupid bloody universe would produce smoke like this? It's like yes, well, that's the more likely outcome and
The Lord said unto cain why art thou wroth and why is thy countenance fallen?
if
Thou doest well shalt thou would not be accepted now
That's an interesting line because and I've looked at a variety of different translations of this this
Seventh verse here like a bunch of them because
The translation for that that's a critical line and the translation really matters and so I'll tell you what I think the story is
but I've been able to figure out and
I'm sure I haven't got it completely right, but it's
So he asks the God says to them if you do well won't you be accepted. What is the hint there, right?
It's something like well things aren't going so well for you, so
The first thing you might think is
You're not doing well. What does that mean? You're not doing good does that not mean you're not acting properly means
It's the hint because God is suggesting that if you were doing properly you would be
successFul I
had a friend at one point who was a very bitter person, and he had a bunch of problems and
some of them were self-inflicted and some of them were fate I suppose and
He had he had become very very destructive Murderously destructive genocide, ly destructive
I would say you could see it in his dreams and and
he lived with me for a while and
I
Knew him very well he was a friend of mine from the time. I was 12 until the time he committed suicide
he was spoke 40 and
When he lived with me, I was trying to help him get on his feet
which was why he had come to live with me because he thought maybe I could help him you know on his feet and
He could only take
Relatively low level jobs. You know like he had some mechanical ability didn't he didn't get educated although. He's a very very smart person
He probably had an Iq about 135 or something like that
He's very smart and so he was bitter too because he hadn't educated himself to the level that his
Education select would have demanded so he had to take jobs that were beneath him
Intellectually and he had a really had that real intellectual arrogance
You know because he was smart and really smart people often come to believe that
Only Smart Matters and if they're smart and all that and all that matters is smart
And then the world is sort of laying itself at their feet then they've been terribly betrayed and and then they cling to their
Intelligence which is more like a talent or a gift like it's a like. It's an idol. You know a False idol
which is exactly what it is in a very dangerous one and
Get cynical about the stupidity of the world and the fact that their talents weren't properly recognized, and that's just not that helpful
You know because smart is a good thing, but I'll tell you if you don't use it properly it will devour. You just like all
arbitrarily assigned Talent, right
So you might have a talent but it's your friend
If you use it properly, and if you excuse it it will be your enemy
And maybe that's how God keeps the cosmic scales adjusted, but anyhow my friend was a very smart person although
Not as smart as he thought he was unfortunately and and but he hadn't done
What would have been necessary with that intelligence to make it manifest itself?
Properly in the world and that also embittered him because he also knew that
There was more that he could have done if he would have done it and perhaps more that he could still do what I was
Suggesting to him while he was living with us because he was you know
two levels from Homeless by that point
Was that he should find a job that he could find?
Working in a in a garage working in a shop something like that cuz he had some mechanical ability and that he should
Do he should separate himself from the arrogance that made him presume that such a job would beneath him?
Because at that point no job was beneath him and but more importantly it's not so obvious that jobs are beneath people
you know because even if you're a even if the imagine you have a job as a
checkout
Person in a in a grocery store, you know it's a fairly unskilled job
You can be in some miserable resentful horrid bastard doing that job boy
you know you can come in there just exuding resentment bitterness and making fakes and
Making sure that every customer that passes by you has a slightly worse day than they need to right and and you know
Pilfering time and Perhaps pilfering goods and being resentful about the people who?
Who gave you the position because they're above you in the dominance hierarchy and talking you know bad things
Gossiping behind the back of your co-workers. It's like you can take your menial position
Self-described and turn that into a very nice little slice of hell
That's for sure, and you know you go into places like that
I always think of the archetypal diner in that way you know you guys have been in this diner
There's a really good opposite diner, and there's a great video on YouTube
it's Tom waits reading reading a poem by
Bukowski, and I think it's called Nirvana
and it's about a good diner that he happened to visit Bukowski happened to visit when he was on a bus when he was a
When he was a kid a diner where everything was going well, and you could listen to that. It's great
I think it's great, but this is the opposite diner. I'm thinking wow so you go into a diner, right?
It's seven o'clock in the morning
And you order some bacon and eggs and some toast and then you look around in the diner and you think
It was like
1975 when the windows were last washed and there's this kind of thick coating of who gives a damn grease on the on
The Walls you know and and the floor too has got that sort of stickiness that you really have to work out to develop over
Years you know and the waitress is
she's not happy to be there and the guy behind the counter isn't happy that that happens to be the waitress that he's working with
And then you know you walk down the stairs. Maybe to the washroom, and that's its own little trip
So you come back and you order your damn eggs?
And you order your toast in the order your bacon
And then it comes and like the eggs are too cooked on the bottom
So they're kind of brown, and then they're kind of raw on top and and they're cold in the middle
Which is you really have to work the cooking egg like that man
But you can master that with like ten years of bitterness you teach how to cook an egg like that
and then the toast here's what you do with the toast right you put
You take you take the white bread you know the pre sliced
Stuff that no one should ever eat then you put that in the toaster
And you overcook it and then you wait
and then you pop it out of the toaster and then because it's overcooked you scrape it off and
You knock off the crumb
So it doesn't look too burnt
and then you wait till it's cold and then you put
Cold Margarine on it because if you put cold first of all not butter
but if you put cold margarine or you can also kind of tear holes in it so that then it has
Lumps of margarine in it and it's really dry except where it's too greasy so that's like your own little work of art man
And then you put that on the side with the with. The--
With the eggs, and then you have the potatoes, and this is how you cook the potatoes properly
you know so they're leftover potatoes and
You keep dumping new Leftover potatoes into the old leftover potatoes over weeks
And so some of the potatoes have they're no longer potatoes right they've have returned to mother Earth
Huh?
then you flop them on the grill and you sort of
Hide it. Oh you burn them a bit. I guess and then you've slapped them on the plate and jesus you don't eat those man
That's for sure, and that's the point and then
You have the bacon and you want to make sure you buy the lowest possible quality bacon, not such
Let's how you start and then you throw it on the grill
And you don't your grill has to be?
Overheated to do this you have to cook the bacon so that it's raw in places and burnt in other places and it has that
Delightful picked like odor that only really cheap badly cooked bacon can provide or may we use those little breakfast sausages that
no one in their bloody right mind would let within 15 feet of anything living you know and
Then you serve that right, and you serve it with the kind of orange juice that is only orange in color
and then with coffee, that's ah
What would you say? It was started too early in the morning. That's the first thing
Bad quality coffee started too early in the morning
got cold once or twice and has been reheated and then you serve that with
Whitener
Like here's your breakfast. It's like no, man. That's not breakfast. That's hell
no, and
And you created it
and
Then what you do if you have a diner like that is because you have a miserable life if you have a diner like that
And you've really worked on achieving that is every night you go home and you curse your wife
And you curse your kids
And you fucking well cursed God too for producing a universe where a diner like yours is allowed to exist
And that's your bloody life
so
Also, that's what God is trying to point out here is
If thou doest well shalt thou not be accepted
and
If thou doest not well then sin lies at your door well, so what I looked at lots of translations for this and actually
The next line is and unto these unto thee shall be his desire
Yes
What God actually says is something like this is like
You know things aren't going so well for you
But if you were behaving properly they would but instead this is what you've done sin came to your door and sin means to you
Know pull your arrow back and to miss the Target sin came to your door
But he uses a metaphor and the metaphor is something like sin came to your door like this
sexually aroused
cat Predator thing and
You invited it in first, and then you let it have its way with you. It's like you entered into a creative
uses of sexual metaphor he entered into a creative exchange with it and
gave birth to something as a consequence and that what you gave birth to you that that's your life and and
You knew it you're self conscious after all you knew you were doing this and you?
conspired with
this thing
To produce the situation that you're in
Young said something about this
similar about the Eatable mother situation
Sorry, it was very politically incorrect what he said of course every single thing
He wrote was politically incorrect so just how you could tell he was a thinker by the way
He talked about the unholy alliance between hyper dependent children and their mothers and he said well
It's actually because you probably thought about it as a as a maternal thing
I'm not putting freud down because freud mapped out the oedipal situation brilliantly
I'm not putting 4i down, but you know jung was taking the ideas and expanding them Outward
and you know he said that there was an actually an unholy alliance between a hyper dependent child and a
And they need to pull over dependent mother and the alliance was the mother would always offer
so maybe the kid is supposed to go off and do something that would require a little bit of courage and effort and
The mother says well are you sure you're feeling well enough to do it and then the child could say
Yes
Or the child could say no, and then you know be put in bed
And maybe didn't all of that and but the thing is the child
Made the damn decision too, and you might think well, that's pretty harsh, but just because children are little doesn't mean. They're stupid and
You don't know children if you don't know how children know how to manipulate
Because they are staggeringly good at that because they're studying you non-stop trying to figure out
what you're up to and be how they can get what they want in the way that they wanted and so they can play a
Manipulative game no problem especially if they're well schooled in it, and so it's sort of like that. It's like
Maybe the mother is a little too a little timid and a little inclined to overprotect and maybe the child is a little
manipulative and a little willing to not take that courageous step out in the world and to
regress into infantile dependency
Instead and then you get a terrible dynamic building across time that is like a vicious circle
you know or like a positive feedback loop that just expands and expands and expands because sometimes in families you see a
Hyper dependent child and a perfectly independent child in same mother so obviously
Same there. I mean mother's very complex and mother for child a and mother for Child B
Are not the same mother even if they happen to be the same human being that literature is quite clear on that
But you get my point, but god's idea was
not only are you not doing well because
You're not doing well
But you're not doing well because you've actually really spent a lot of work figuring out how to not do well
this is like creative effort on your part and if you read about
Truly malevolent people and you could start with the Columbine killers because they left some very interesting diaries behind
So I would recommend them if you there plenty of serial killers you could read about in the people
Who've really gone out and done dark things
And I've read more than my fair share of that sort of thing and understand it quite well
If you really want to have your countenance fall and be roth
Ten years of brooding on
your own catastrophe
Sort of a loan and
Letting your fantasies. Take shape and
endi and egging them on and and
Allowing them to flourish and let's say take possession of you because that's exactly the right way to think of it. That will get you
Somewhere like this and there are more people who are like that than you think and you're more like that than you think
Well so kayne he's obviously not very happy about this whole answer obviously
Because the last thing you want to hear if your life is turned into a catastrophe and you
Take God to task for creating a universe where that sort of thing was allowed is that?
It's your own damn fault
And you should straighten up and fly right so to speak and you shouldn't be complaining about the nature of being
But that is the answer he gets and so then what happens
well we have to infer that if kane was angry before that he's a lot more angry now and
Of course that's exactly
what the story reveals and cain talked with abel his brother and
It came to pass when they were in the field that cain rose up against abel his brother and slew him
I'm going to read you something else now
This is foreshadowing again
This is from the same chapter by the way
Do what is Meaningful not what is expedient?
Jesus was Led into the wilderness according to the story to be tempted by the devil Matthew 4:1 prior to his crucifixion
This is the story of cain
Restated abstractly cain is far from happy as we have seen he's working hard or so he thinks but God is not pleased
Meanwhile Abel is dancing away in the daisies his crops flourish women love him first of all. He's a pretty good guy
Everyone oh is it he deserves his good fortune all the more reason to hate him
I used to joke when I used to teach at Harvard and now and then my wife would have some of the undergraduates over
We used to joke afterwards because some of them were many of them were very remarkable kids. You know like they
They were super smart they were athletic or they had some dramatic ability or they were musicians, or they done some spectacular
Charitable work because he basically to get
Accepted into harvard you had to be top of your damn school
And then you had to have at least two other outstanding things going for you
You know and what was so annoying about most of these kids
This was our joke with you really both liked them and respected them
It's like we my joke was do you think they would have had the good graces to be like?
Dislikeable sons of bitches at least with all the all those other great things going for them. They had to act like
Respectability and like ability to it as well, so you thought well, you know it really couldn't happen to a better person
It's like good. God well, that's that's that's able situation. You know it's like and you know the funny thing, too
Is that that's an ideal? That's the ideal right because an ideal person let's say would be
someone who you would want to be like and and someone who is operating in the world like you would want to operate and
Someone whom fortune was smiling on and someone who is making the right sacrifices. It's really what you would want to be and
So can kill that?
Right so it's a psychological story too, and you see this in the cynicism that people have about
People who have done well in the world. They're always looking for some reason. Why they've done well
they must be crooked or they must be they must be conniving or they must be arrogant or they must be
psychopathic or you know and of course all of those things exist
But it's a very bad trick to play on yourself to make the proposition that the person in the world who?
represents your own ideal is that ideal because of
Despicable reasons because what you do is train yourself that the ideal that you should pursue can only exist if it's motivated by
Despicable reasons, and then what not only is able your brother dad as your brother in the field in reality
But you've also slaughtered your own ideal
Well, then what the hell are you going to work for well? How are you gonna live then?
Well bitterly and miserably that's for sure
Bitterly miserably and hopelessly that's how you're going to live you know it's so rare that I see
especially
publicly
that people
Honestly admit with sports figures. They'll do it. That's that's one place where that seems to happen, but it's so uncommon for
expressions of admiration and gratitude to
manifest themselves in any public
communication of any Sort newspapers TV
YouTube Twitter, it's almost always
Undermining and backbiting and criticism and very often directed to people who?
Who have often done little else, but?
Bring good things into the world for other people, and that's part of why this is such a profound story
He's a pretty good guy everyone knows that he deserves his good fortune all the more reason to hate him
That's for sure kane broods on his misfortune like a vulture on an egg
He enters the desert wilderness of his own mind. He
Obsesses over his ill fortune and betrayal he nourishes his resentment
He indulges in ever more elaborate fantasies of revenge
His arrogance grows to Luciferian proportions. I'm ill used and oppressed
He thinks this is a stupid bloody planet it can go to hell
And with that he encounters Satan in the wilderness and falls prey to his temptations
And he does what he can in John Milton's unforgettable words
To confound the race of mankind in the first route and mingle and involve Earth with hell
done all
despite the Great creator
He turns to evil to obtain what good forbade him, and he does it voluntarily self consciously and with malice.
Let him who has ears hear.
So that's the first two human beings. The resentful, bitter, failure
taking an axe to the admirable success
Then the Lord said unto cain. Where is abel thy brother, and he said I know not am I my brother's keeper
and
He said what hast thou done the voice of thy brother's blood crieth unto me from the ground?
Now art thou cursed from the Earth which hath opened her mouth to receive thy brother's blood from thy hand
You know if you want to understand that which I would recommend you could read Dostoyevsky's
Crime and punishment
That's a great
It's a great novel. I think it might be the greatest novel ever written because I haven't read every novel
But in my experience, it's the greatest novel and it is exactly this it
It says what happens psychologically if you commit the ultimate crime
It's amazing. It's absolutely amazing it's it's it's
There's
There's no psychologist like dostoyevsky
We now tell us the ground it shall not henceforth Yield unto thee her strength
A fugitive and a vagabond shalt thou be in the Earth and cain said unto the Lord
My punishment is greater than I can bear now one of the things that's interesting about this is that you know it
I think the punishment that God lays on cain is
It's like the inevitable consequences of cain's action. It's something like that. It's like well. He killed his brother
There's no going back from that man like
good luck forgiving yourself for
That especially if he was an ideal, especially if he was your ideal because he haven't just killed your brother and of course
tortured your parents and the rest of your family you've deprived the community of someone who is upstanding and
You did it for the worst possible motivations. It's like
There's no
up from there right that's
That's as close to hell as you could manage on Earth
I would say and kane said unto the lord my punishment is greater than I can bear
Behold thou hast driven me out this day from the face of the earth and from thy face shall I be hid
Doubt to is like there's also no
Turning back to God let's say after an error like that because well
You've done everything you possibly could to spite
God
Assuming he exists and the probability that you're going to be able to mend that relationship in your now broken state
When you couldn't mend it to begin with before you did something so terrible
starts to move towards zero and
It shall come to pass that everyone that findeth me shall slay me and the Lord said unto him there for
whosoever Slayeth cain Vengeance Shall be taken on Him, Sevenfold
And the Lord said a mark upon cain lest any finding him should kill him that's an interesting thing
I wanted about that for a long time because you might think well
Why would God take cain under his wing so to speak given? What's already happened, and I think it has something to do with
The emergence of the idea that it was necessary to prevent tit-for-tat
revenge slayings, it's something like that you know and
And there's hints of that later in the text because you know it's like
Well, I kill your brother and then you kill two of my brothers
And then I kill your whole family and then you kill my whole town
And then I kill your whole country and then we blow up the world. It's like. Yeah, that's probably not a very
intelligent
solution to the Initial
Problem even though the initial problem which might be a murder is not an easy thing to solve
But I think it's something like that and then the last part of the story is
God's William Blake
so Adam and eve have discovered their dead son, and
cain
Has become cognizant. I would say of what he did and what he is
right so it's another entrance into a form of self-consciousness, it's it's
You know the self-consciousness that Adam and Eve developed was painful enough
They become aware of their own vulnerability in their nakedness and perhaps even their capacity for evil, but cain becomes aware of his
Voluntary engagement with Evil itself and
sees that as a crucial
Human capability
And that's something modern people. You know it's no wonder we don't take it seriously like I know in the academy and
Among intellectual circles for decades the idea of Evil has been it's like
What are you?
Medieval or something you know the whole idea of evil you don't that's a non-starter as an intellectual
Starting place as a as a topic and that's something that I've just been unable to understand because I cannot understand how you could possibly
Have more than a cursory knowledge of the history of the 20th century
much much less a deep knowledge of the history of the 20th century and
To walk away with any other conclusion, then well good might not exist but evil hey
the Evidence for that is
So overwhelming that
That only willful blindness could possibly explain denying in its existence
and
That was actually a useful discovery for me
because I also
concluded
Perhaps that if it was true evil existed then it
It was true by inference that its opposite existed
Because the opposite of evil. Let's say the evil of the concentration camp. Let's say or we could get more specific about it
We could say there's this one thing that used to happen in our Switz
where they would take
People off the incoming trains those who lived you know that weren't stacked around the outside of the train
Train
Cars and you know froze to death because it was too cold
You know those who only had to be stuck in the middle where it was warm enough
So that maybe the old people died because they suffocated
But at least some of them were alive when they made it to our sweats
and then they took those poor people out one of the tricks that the guards used to play on them was to have the
the Newly arrived prisoners
Hoist like hundred pound sacks of wet salt and carried them from one side of the compound
And these compounds were big this was a city. It wasn't like a gymnasium
It was like a city there were tens of thousands of people there
they'd have them carry the sack of wet salt from one side of the compound to the other and
then back
right and that was to make a mockery out of the
Notion that work would set you free. It's like no. No you work here, but there's nothing productive about it
The whole point it's exactly the opposite of sacrifice in some sense, it's oh, we're going to make you act out working
But all it will do is speed your demise
and maybe we can decorate it up a little bit because not only will it speed up your demise it will do it in a
Very painful way while simultaneously increasing
The probability that other people's demises will be painful and sped up. It's a work of arts. That's for sure and
To to know about that sort of thing and not to not regard it as evil means
Well, you can figure out what it means for yourself
and
Cain went out from the presence of the Lord and dwelt in the land of Nod on the east of Eden
cain knew his wife and she conceived you know and one of the critics the criticisms are fairly common criticism of
These biblical stories is well if cain and Abel were the only two
People and from Adam and eve. It's like where did all these other people come from and doesn't that make the story?
Like simple-Minded it's like no that makes the reader simple-Minded
You know I mean really that's the best criticism of this you're going to come up with I mean absolutely
missed the point that that would be the right response you missed the point and
Cain knew his wife and she conceived and bare enoch
And he builded the city and so it's cain that builds the cities and starts the civilization and called that's pretty rough too, right?
so it's the first fratricidal murderer who builds the cities after the name of his son enoch and
unto enoch was born around ETc Etc
Going through the generations and lamech took unto him two wives the name of the one without on the name of the other zillah
this is a an
attempt to Flesh out the genealogy and to describe how culture started in some sense in these tribal communities and
Ada bear jebel and he was the father of such as dwell in tents and of such as have cattle and
His brother's name was jubal
and he was the father of all such handle the harp and organ and zilla she also bear tubal-cain an
instructor of error every artificer in brass and Iron
Tubal-cain
traditionally is the first person who makes weapons of war and lamech back to Lamech a
Descendant of cain
Said unto his wives adah and Zillah hear my voice
he wise of lamech Hearken unto my speech for I have slain a man to my wounding and a young man to my hurt if
Cain be avenged Sevenfold Truly Lamech seventy and Sevenfold
Well what I see, and that is this
proclivity of this
murderous capacity of cain as it manifests itself as society develops to
To a murderous intent that transcends the mirror killing of a brother
You hurt me I hurt you back. No. You heard me. I kill you in six other people and
The thing that happens after that is to not make it seven people
But to make it seventy people, and so there's this idea that once that
that first
Murderous
Seed is sown
It has this proclivity to
Manifest itself exponentially and that's a warning and that's also why I think Tubal cain
Who's one of cain's descendants was the first person who made?
weapons of War
And that's pretty much the story of cain and Abel and it's a hell of a story
as far as I can tell and I think it's worth thinking about pretty much forever because
there's so many so many it has so many facets you know and I think the
most
usefully revealing of those facets is the
The potential for the story once understood to shed light on not
your own failure not even on your
rejection by being let's say
but by the but on the
proclivity to
murder
the best and the best in you
for revenge upon that
violation
because
What that means and we know that knowledge of good and evil into the world so to speak with Adam and eve's transgression is
That now not only does humanity have to contend with
Tragedy and suffering and even the
unharvested fruits of Proper Sacrifice, But with the introduction of real Malevolence into the world, so
There's the fall
into history, and then there's the discovery of
Sacrifice as a medication for the fall and then there's a counter position
which is the emergence of malevolence as the enemy of proper Sacrifice and
that's where we're left at the end of
cain and Abel and
That's the end of that lecture. Thank
Alright
ok so you said that one of your moral axioms is that pain is bad and
So we should work to eliminate unnecessary suffering
Isn't this the basis for a secular morality like utilitarianism and can we therefore be Moral without religion?
Well, I don't think that its first of all probably
To the first question, but that's also
that
Derivation is predicated on the idea that that's the only idea
You know that I'm putting forward as a ethical idea, and it's not if that was the only idea well
Then you could derive from that a fairly straightforward brand of utility utilitarianism, but that also I think to
Push the argument in that direction also
Necessitates the reduction of what might constitute pain to something to uni-dimensional
Because I think suffering is better term than pain although pain in some sense is at the core of suffering
Suffering is a multi-dimensional
phenomena, and I don't think that you can draw a
simple utilitarian argument from
that
either the existence of suffering or the observation that it's
The reduction of unnecessary suffering might be a good thing
So I'm also leery of those
see it's not reasonable in some sense to reduce a
complex set of ideas to a single proposition
And then say the ideas that I've been putting forward and then to reduce another complex philosophical
Set of ideas to a single proposition, and then say aren't those two things the same and they are to reduce them to the two
simple axioms or you could argue that they're the same but
but you but I would say there's a
Tremendous amount left out in the telling and that what's left out is relevant it kind of reminds me of those
Those philosophical games that pSychologists often play. It's like well, if there was I?
Think when I what's the one, I don't know if I can
recall this properly
It's the trolley cart problem
something like
You know if there was a train that was out of control and it was
going towards
Six people on one track when you flip a switch, so it's switched tracks and only killed one person
Would you do that and I read a question like that. I think
that's a stupid question and the reason I think that is because
you can't take a situation like that and
Render it
Properly by reducing it to that question and then you also can't assume that
The person who answers that question would in fact act in the way they answered you can't presume any of that
it's like because in a situation like that in a
High-stress situation like that the
Devil is in the details
And I've dealt with situations like that a number of times and know perfectly well that the devils in the detail
so I think that there's a
there's an intellectual reduction to make a philosophical point that doesn't give the complexity of the topic Justice and
then
there's a second part to that which was and
Therefore can't we be Moral without religion. Well I
Would say that question also suffers in some sense from the same
Problem of formulation, I I'm very
Hesitant ever to answer a question of the form is a
Merely a manifestation of B
When a and B are very complex things because the answer that is it depends on what you mean by Moral
And what you mean by religious?
because
You see there's an underlying
intellectual
maneuver in in a question like that and
The underlying maneuver is the a priori
assumption that something as complex as religion or as complex as morality can be reduced to an
object with a name and that
Then two objects reduced to the name can be assessed simultaneously, and I don't think that that's the case I think
you can say something like
Is a triangle a square, I think you can say that but I don't think you can say
Is it possible to have morality without religion? I don't think you can have that question because it it has to be expanded out
So it's like what do you mean by morality exactly and what do you mean by religion because maybe and maybe not and so?
And so the answer to that question is to decompose the question I
Don't want my young children indoctrinated with dangerous ideas
and as time marches on I trust public education less and less I
Know that you have strong thoughts on the danger of the devouring oedipal mother who harms your child by protecting them
And that's certainly not what I aspire to I
Wonder if in spite of your idea that kids need to become tough and learn to slay dragons if you have anything good to say
about the idea of homeschooling
Well, I don't have anything bad to say about it
I do know that the
Quebec government has recently taken moves to make it much more difficult for people to homeschool their children
And it's not like five years. I mean
15 Years Ago I
Would have presumed that the vast majority of people who were homeschooling their children were
To be viewed with skepticism
Initially I'm not so sure about that anymore
You know for example. I was sent a poster today
someone sent me this link that they found in the local junior high school and one of the
Media pieces that were recommended on this poster was a movie called Hedwig and the angry inch
now I
Thought that was a terrible movie even though. I'm perfectly capable of enjoying bizarre movies, but so it's a bizarre movie
That's for sure, but I also thought it was a terrible bitter
Movie terrible and bitter those are separate a movie can be bitter and be quite great
But it was a terrible movie and it was a bitter movie, but I can tell you one bloody thing about that movie
It's not required viewing for twelve-Year-old kids that's for sure, so
I think you have increasing reason to be skeptical of the public education system. I also looked at the
elementary teachers federation of Ontario's
guidelines for education from Kindergarten to Grade 8 and what that is in
essence, and I think I will do a video about it in the relatively near future is a
blueprint for transforming children into social Justice warriors it basically says that
It's like you don't have to be a conspiracy theory to read that I mean we have social justice
tribunals in Ontario and so the idea is well if you're going to get your children if you're going to get people to
What would you say favor equity?
Properly well then you better start teaching them well. They're young it's like
maybe not
So now you you ask that question properly because you say well
The terrible education system the wonderful mother homeschooling right? That's the danger
it's like no because it might not be the wonderful mother homeschooling it might be the
pathological mother using the Pathology of the education system as a
Excuse to get her talons into her children right because that's certainly
Equally possible or perhaps even more possible because at least in the public education system. There's some
Necessity for consensus, so
To have something that you have to be very
Aware of and work to prevent right and so I would say if you're going to do that
Probably best not to do it on your own
And you need it's like you need a board of advisors or something like that
And so maybe it can't just be you and you have to figure out well, what what is the Aim?
And how are you going to manage that and what makes you think you can do it even if it's being done badly?
Publicly, what makes you think you could do it better
I mean my general advice is and people have asked me this in fact
I had a conversation with the guy who was Tyler my
Backyard this morning about something his son had said to him that he was taught at school recently
Which really made the Tyler who had come from a rather authoritarian country?
Step back on his heels and think I'm not so sure I should be sending my kid to public school anymore
and maybe I shouldn't be living in Toronto even you know but
my general advice is keep an eye on your kids and discuss with them what they're learning and and
help equip them with the tools to
not only to
articulate Their own Viewpoint in
Response to what they're being taught now if the problem is you might not have the time nor the ability to do that?
that's no simple thing and
increasingly if you're unwilling to
Have your children participate in what is increasingly?
indoctrination and not education thanks to in no small part to the Ontario institute of studies on education which is an
Institution that I particularly despise because I think that all it does is almost all it does now is produce
indoctrinate Errs of Children
It's not an easy. It's not an easily easy problem to solve
so
more more power to you wanting to
Put your children in a situation where they're not being indoctrinated
But the alternative is very very complicated and difficult
so
Yeah
likely
You know I would say
Generally speaking
there's a shamanic basis to to almost all the religious traditions because
That's the milieu out of which the religious traditions Emerge now. I can't say much more than that because I don't know
And no one does that
The particularity mean you might say well is there an allusion to the ingestion of psychoactive?
chemicals in the Adam and Eve story
And people have made that case and there's been powerful cases made so there's a book for example
I think it's called Soma by a guy named Gordon Wausau who was the first person an amateur?
mycologist who was the first person to propose that the soma of the
Hindus was we're at Amanita Muscaria mushrooms
Which is actually a those are the the red mushrooms with the white dots that you always see on Fairytales, you know the cute ones
Toadstools
Flies like to eat them they're called fly agaric also, and why seem to like getting stoned. I know that's weird
I know that's weird thing to say
But there's I have a good book on animal use of psychedelics and more animals use them than you might think
But anyways there is some evidence that
You know of use of of the injecting of fruits let's say
Metaphorically speaking as an aid to the transformation of consciousness that goes back so far that well
forever as far as human beings are concerned, but to
Specifically tie that to the Adam and eve story. I haven't been able to see any evidence. That would definitely link them
You know there's there's been a lot of interesting books written about that. There's one. That was quite a
kind of a weird hit
And I think in the early late 60s might have been early 70s sort of got brushed off as a hippie book
But it really wasn't it's called the sacred mushroom in the cross
Absolutely, that's the sort of book you read you think huh I?
Don't know
what to do about that I have no idea what to do about that look so
That's all I can say about that
Yep
my questions about martyrdom so um
what do you think martyrdom or the willingness to suffer and die for what you believe if anything says of the conviction and
What do you think is the benefit for the Martyr which is at least traditionally?
immaterial and transcendent good compared to the regular sacrifice or practical
Sacrifice which is ordered to the future material psychological or economic good?
Man You guys really come up with some wicked questions. I
Think it depends to some degree on how you define martyrdom
you know
because you could you could define it as the
Tendency to pathologically self aggrandizing self on public display, or you
Could say it's the decision to be immovable about a set of principles right so let's go with that one forget about the first one
well, I wouldn't recommend it to anyone right in some sense it's it's
That's a really tough one
People ask me. I'll make it personal
I suppose people asked me when I first got involved in saw this political controversy back in September October
well
They asked me a couple of things they they asked me if this was the hill that I really would choose to die on us
like pronouns and the Transgender issue
Yeah, well it's not what about one
I would have picked and but I mean it was about language you know and that that makes it non-trivial
I mean bill C 16 was passed this week as you know and one of the things that was quite interesting about that
I will answer your question was that Brenda Cosman who was the woman that I debated I think it's
One of the persons that I debated didn't like to be referred to as a woman, but I don't didn't think it was Brenda
Anyways, she wrote an op-ed, and I believe it was in the globe and mail
But it might have been the national post saying as I knew she would say that bill C. 16 was just the beginning
That we have plenty of work left to do and yes
You can bloody well be sure that we have plenty of work left to do anyways. I was asked during that period of time
Whether or not I was being a martyr you know, and I thought well. It's not really one of my ambitions
You know it's like that's sort of torn to the lions thing doesn't sound like
exactly something you might aim for
But I think
Well sometimes you find out in your life. Maybe that there's something you won't do and
one thing and
Then maybe you just don't do it no matter what the consequence is
Maybe I don't know because you know I haven't been pushed to that point
But there have been people who have been pushed to that point in history
And they basically said I don't care what you do to me. I'm not doing that and
You know maybe some of them were suicidal and some of them were psychotic and some of them had whatever other problems that people might?
have but yeah, I do have this suspicion now, and then that some of them were just kind of serious about and saying no and
There's some utility in being serious about saying no, and it that sort of revealed itself to me
I suppose to some degree back in September. We and I read a piece of legislation
That said I would have to use some words that were legislated by the government, and I thought there's no goddamn way
I'm going to do that under any conditions that I can imagine now there are conditions
And I have a pretty good imagination for unimaginable conditions. I
Couldn't see it because I thought that if I did that I would break through whatever would be left of me
After having done. That would no longer be me and
I'm not interested in that I know what that would be like
I actually do know what that would be like and I'm not interested in that I would rather have whatever else happens
Happen and people have said to me. Well you're so courageous for taking this stand. It's like yeah, well
I'm not going to claim any sort of other world courage I can tell you that but I can tell but one thing I do
Know the difference between these different forms of hell
Let's put it that way, and there's the hell that maybe I might be dragged through if I don't
Agree
Don't act in accordance with this law
And there's the hell that I would be dragged through if I did act in accordance with the law and I would vastly
Prefer the first hell to the second and isn't clear to me that that actually constitutes courage
Is it useful because that's also the question about martyrdom
I think it's very useful for people to see that someone will say there's no way
there's no conceivable way that you can get me to do that and
and I've thought long and hard about such things too because I've taught very many people to negotiate and
One of the things I always teach them is you don't negotiate from a position of weakness
because you lose and
So if I say no to something, and I mean no, I mean no
I bloody well won't do it
And I think that if there are people who also agree that such things aren't appropriate
To have the example of someone who says no
And means it actually turns out to be useful and so then I would say well that's an inclination in the potential
Direction of Martyrdom and
but I don't see how to distinguish that that from actually just having the courage of your
Convictions, and so sometimes you might say well a person who has sufficient courage in their convictions will sometimes be put to death
Well, if that's the definition of a martyr then
Sometimes but not all of all ways that's a really good thing and one of the things
I really liked about solzhenitsyn's book the gulag archipelago
Which is an I refer to it often it's an absolutely staggering book is that he?
Put in many many stories of people who were in the gulag and they were often religious believers
Which was a shock to him because he was an atheistic Communist when when he first entered the Camp's
They were often religious believers, and they were people who said no
there were things they would not do they would not participate in what the regime was asking them to do and
he you have to read it because the devils in the stories write the details in the stories, but
solzhenitsyn in the Camps grew to have tremendous admiration for such people and actually viewed them as
exemplars of
the mode of being that was
necessary for him to escape both the Communist propaganda that had shaped him as an individual and also the terrible bitterness and
Sorrow and anger that he experienced as a consequence of being flung into the terrible concentration camp conditions of the gulag archipelago
so
Yep
Hey, Doc. Thanks for staying alive and potentially saving humanity
Yeah, that's good stuff. I'm wondering about a couple of things firstly who won that childhood fight. You kind of let that
Let that just slide, so I'm thinking it's a big L. Well, I can tell you because he
Was a tough little kid see I don't remember. What happened
but my remembrance of him was that he could eat pound meal pretty pretty effectively so
Yeah, yeah, his name was Vernon Switchin ik
Yeah, he was really the good friend of mine and and I think I think Vernon still lives in Fairview
so if if he hears of this, then maybe he'll remember that too and and
Know you know
So probably he would have won. I didn't win that many physical fights when I was a kid, so
That's not the only question okay
Anyway cool. I'm not sure if you if you've actually been asked us before I've missed the last two lectures, but I
Wondering what your thoughts are on
Polkan Jr.. Tolkien and his work, not just lord of the rings, but the similar alien
Which is basically like I'm seeing all this and I'm thinking it's like the Modern Bible in a way
it's got the weird names like to Paul cain and all that stuff and
And specifically when we were talking about cain just now and how he was thing just moving
And he was talking about how he felt like betrayed by God and you any misspent his whole life working
It to spite him essentially and he kind of set the path for for the darkness in humanity. Yeah, that's
almost exactly
Melkor which was in the Silmarillion, basically
What's what spawned everything evil in Middle Earth and Mordor and what not and I don't even know
I won't be welcome talking with a student of mythology and you know the the
the
story of the Hobbit is a retelling of beowulf in large part, and that's a dragon slaying myth and and
so the the the reason the tolkien and
rolling for that are so popular is because they've done a very good job of making the old myths new and
And well look what's happened with the marvel series. It's the same thing and with Star wars and all of that
Is that you can't not respond to these stories now. You're going to find them in one form or another and sometimes
well with the biblical stories for example
the mythological the meaning of the mythological content has become
Invisible that's partly the death of God that Nietzsche was referring to but that doesn't mean that the stories themselves
Vanish because people have an eternal hunger for them
Now the problem with them emerging in let's say more literary or less sophisticated
Form let's take the Marvel movies as an example. Is that they're not
Surrounded by an articulated culture the same way the biblical stories are so for example
They're not surrounded by something like Paradise lost by John Milton which or or dante's inferno. Which are works of
unlimited depth and so you throw away something of great value and
Reacquire it in a different place
With less value perhaps, but more comprehensibility. It's not it's not a great trade. That is not a critique of tolkien
it's not a critique of anybody who's drawing on mythological stories for their narratives you have to do that to be a good storyteller, but
it's nice to go as close to the source as you can as well, so
Yeah, and the overlaps that you described well
Yeah
It's exactly what you'd expect because if you deal with great
Mythological themes you start to get the archetypes are at the bottom of stories and so
If the story goes down far enough it runs into the archetypes and that well that was jung's claim
and I think he got that exactly right, so
last one
There's a passage in Paradise lost where
the Demons are building pandemonium under
Mammon's Sort of Guidance, and they crack open the it's not really Earth, but hell
And they take out the gold and they build pandemonium, which is the most sophisticated
Architectural wonder
of all time in Milton's language and
and this this conception of taking material and turning it into a
temple to oneself
was interpreted by humphrey Jennings who was the founder of the mass observation movement if anyone saw the opening to the
Britons 2012 games
The history of the Industrial revolution. He said was encapsulated by this passage in Milton. Where you have
Demons building a temple for themselves out of matter and that mankind in Milton's language was was taught to do this
Or that they learned it first by this example and says let not envy that
devils have riches in hell
And I see things in this one the the gnostic idea that somehow the world itself that we inhabit is hell
ultimate that matter is not our true places of existence, but somewhere is sort of platonic and
Also, the toasty and sort of bargain that people made around
1666 to to get a world of stuff and seeing some possession
by losing a soul
yeah, but existed before that and I wonder if that I play with that a lot in my own thought and I wonder if that's
Something that you found in Milton and what you think of that passage in particular well Milton was definitely a prophetic voice
Right and I think that's that's a perfectly reasonable
Retelling of that
Section it's also very much akin to the story of the tower of babel. We'll talk about next week
See the problem with the problem. God
it's so complicated see what one of the things that jung said about the transformation of
The first millennium of Christianity into let's say the second millennium of Christianity was that Christianity had promised
something like redemption universal redemption from suffering
Maybe in the afterlife, but that was kind of a cop-out
let's say because it didn't really solve the problem of suffering here and now and you believe that as
People had although although it
Did many it did many positive things?
Let's not let's not forget that it civilized people in a way that they hadn't been before or you could make that case
But then there was this underground
at the same time there's this denial of the utility of material reality that went along with the
spiritualization of mankind in that in that first in the Christian millennium
there was value left in material because it had been ignored and so then jung believed that the
the collective unconscious broadly speaking
Began to be attracted to the to what had been rejected by the hyper
spiritualization and started to question whether or not additional value could be extracted from the material may be as a
adjunct to the spiritual because maybe true redemption was something like a
proper meeting of the spiritual in the material which wasn't
Something that seemed to be part and parcel of Christian Christian doctrine up to that point
now
Maybe what Milton was warning against was a swing to far, right?
And I think Milton's point is well-taken because one of the things that's worth noting is that
You can be perfectly miserable in a house of gold
right I mean I've known very many wealthy people very very wealthy people and
The problem see the thing is is that money just doesn't solve that many problems that people have
people wish it would
People who want to be rich think it will and the people who want to?
Redistribute money think it will and I know that there's nothing to be said for abject poverty, but the problem is is that
There are many see arius problems that human beings have that matter
material
Comfort alone does nothing to address
or almost nothing you can be perfectly you can have a perfectly miserable family life and twenty million dollars and
The buffer that the twenty million dollars puts between you and the misery is it sometimes. It's not even a buffer. It's a magnifier, so
melding would warn against
the creation of
even the idea of a material utopia even in principle
Something dostoevsky also recognized as an error
You cannot solve the problem in that Manner and maybe the demonic idea is
that is
propaganda that you could
now maybe
Maybe there is a balance of some sort because I don't understand if we were going to build the city of God let's say
well a huge part of the endeavor would have to be spiritual and
to me that a huge part of that would be it would have to be something predicated if
Not on truth at least not at least on the willingness of people not to lie to one another
Without that all the material well-being in the world is
It's a façade. It's like gilding a corpse, right?
And I think that's partly what Milton was warning against
I mean Milton was doing many more things than he knew of course because he was a poetic genius of
incalculable
genius
right right right
right so well you've obviously thought about such things very much, so that was a very good question, so
Alright everyone, good night.